[Aplausos]
muchas gracias muy buenas tardes
yo cuando estaba chico tenía más o menos
como 4 o 5 años yo quería un cd ese era
lo que quería comprar esa era mi meta en
la vida un cedé muchos de ustedes
probablemente ni se acuerdan que existen
los cities y probablemente menos se
acuerdan cuánto costaba un cid y bueno
cuando yo estaba chico costaban como 100
pesos y hacer el estándar y había un
grupo que me encantaba que se llama corn
y a mucha gente probablemente tampoco lo
conoce pero una banda de rock que la
neta me ha encantado
col
100 pesos costa del cid y llego con mis
papás y les digo me pueden dar 100 pesos
para comprar este si me dicen baja
limpia los baños de la casa
así se lavan los baños de la casa
llego con mis papás se habían se habían
ido llego con mi hermano al que le
dejaron el dinero me dio 50 pesos no sé
si se robó en los otros 50 mis papás de
amanda dejaron esos 50 pero bueno tenía
50 pesos llegó a la tienda donde venden
todos los civis checo el siri de con 100
pesos me faltaban 50 en eso me empiezo a
ir de la tienda
a dónde vas le dije tengo 50 pesos no me
alcanza en un señor con barba la neta es
que no me creo cómo se llama yo le puse
don pepe
no sé si siga vivo
y me dice por qué no compras el sigue
los black eyed peas que está al lado y
que está el 50% de descuento lo agarra
se lo vendes a un amigo tuyo y adivina
que todo el mundo sabe que los cides
cuestan 50 100 pesos lo vas a poder
vender y vas a poder comprar tus idecon
pues así dice y esa fue la primera
lección de negocios que alguien me dio
en la vida compra barato y vende caro
esa fue la primera lección que alguien
medio después crecí entre a la prepa
universidad y gané mi primer sueldo y
adivinen qué hice con mi primer sueldo
lo que me todito me lo gasté en un
iphone
el iphone era como creo que el iphone 4
era el que todos tenían y pues yo quería
no pertenecer y que todos me vieran con
el iphone lo compré me gasté todos mis
ahorros y mi primer sueldo me lo robaron
a la semana
pero entendí algo el morís con el primer
sueldo y el morís que quería el cid y no
es muy distinto las metas habían
cambiado ahora ya no quería un cedé
ahora quería irme de viaje ahora quería
comprar una casa empezar a crear mi
patrimonio
fundar una empresa crecer una familia
tenía distintas metas
pero igual me di cuenta de otra cosa
necesitas saber administrar tu dinero
para poder alcanzar todos estos
objetivos en la vida me di cuenta de
tres cosas 1
no hay don pepe s la vida no pueden ser
estudie secundaria prepa carrera
y me gradué y me di cuenta que no tenía
ni idea sobre las finanzas
yo soy ingeniero
algo tan fundamental que es como en cómo
alcanzar tus objetivos en la vida cómo
utilizar las finanzas pasarelas alcanzar
me di cuenta que no tenía ni idea y que
no había don pepe es que me enseñaran
como aquella vez que quería comprar mi
sede
también me di cuenta que en el ramo
financiero no era el único que no sabía
siete calles mexicanos sin ahorros para
el retiro
que el retiro nos presenta bastantes
problemas importantes en méxico las
ciudades afores no necesitas aportar
voluntariamente porque si no te vas a
retirar con digamos que no tanto dinero
no el tema financiero en méxico es un
tema importante y hay mucha
desinformación y me di cuenta que
necesitas finanzas para alcanzar tus
objetivos
las finanzas son como el concreto que
construye el edificio de tus sueños esta
es tu vida tu vida es el proyecto el
dinero es el concreto con el que
construyes y alcanzar tus objetivos
hay muchos tabús respecto al dinero pero
la verdad es que el dinero no es otra
cosa más que el medio para alcanzar tus
objetivos y me di cuenta de una tercera
cosa que es
no soy el único que estudia esta carrera
y no tengo ni idea de cómo administrar
mis finanzas cómo gastarlo cómo
administrarlo cómo hacerlo crecer
cuántos somos los universitarios en
mexico
así que con esto en mente decidí empezar
una aventura yo me gradué que sería
entrar a consultoría negocios porque si
ayuda a las empresas a crecer voy a
ayudar a las personas a crecer dije qué
pasa si en vez de asesorar empresas
asesor o una por una asesoró a un tamaño
muy muy pequeño de empresas que se
llaman personas igual con objetivos
igual necesitan finanzas para alcanzar
sus objetivos
y mi objetivo fue transformar la cultura
financiera en méxico
y transformarla
un objetivo bastante agresivo bastante
no bastante grande pero ese fue mi
objetivo
y usted se preguntará en una solicitud
como un chavo de 26 años cómo va a
lograr transformar la cultura financiera
en méxico
pues yo lewis decir como y es la misma
forma en la que ustedes pueden generar
el cambio que se propongan en la vida y
pueden llevar a cabo el proyecto que
estén planeando pensando y es con un
concepto financiero valga la redundancia
valga la relación es con un concepto
financiero y el concepto financiero es
el interés compuesto desgraciadamente en
méxico no es muy conocido el interés
compuesto con otros países que es muy
muy conocido el concepto del interés
compuesto para los que no sepan que es
el interés compuesto voy a hacer un
pequeño ejercicio muy rápido hablando de
las inversiones y lo voy a comparar
contra su hermano menor su hermano
enemigo el interés simple si yo
invirtiera 100 pesos al 10% anual a tasa
fija a interés a interés fijo perdón
el primer año me daría 10 10 pesos de
rendimiento el segundo año me daría
otros días y el tercer año me daría
otros días ese es una inversión a tasa
fija
pero qué pasa si yo invierto con el
interés compuesto
son los 100 pesos el primer año me va a
dar los días el segundo año me va a dar
el rendimiento sobre el rendimiento y el
capital inicial es decir sobre los 100 y
sobre los 10 que gane el primer año que
quiere decir que en el segundo año voy a
ganar 11 y el tercer año voy a ganar
12.1 y así sucesivamente déjenme déjenme
entender que es lo que están pensando
ustedes maurice esos incrementos son
marginales si tienes razón son
marginales pero esto es una comparación
entre una gráfica del interés simple
contra una gráfica del interés compuesto
en un inicio los cambios son marginales
pero en el futuro adivina que también
son marginales pero son incrementos
sobre incrementos el interés compuesto
es el concepto en financiero más
importante saben por qué porque no tiene
nada que ver con finanzas
el interés compuesto tiene que ver con
nuestra vida
con como nosotros crecemos como personas
y como crecemos como profesionistas ese
es él todos los días
disciplinar te hacer 1% mejor en todos
nuestros aspectos mañana ser mejor que
hoy y pasado mañana vas a hacerlo mejor
que hoy sino que mañana
esto aplica para todos nuestros
proyectos en la vida cuando te decides
empezar a hacer ejercicio cuando te
decides empezar a leer cuando te decides
a crear un hábito positivo cuando te
decides emprender saben cuál es el
problema especialmente nosotros los
millennials que somos muy desesperados
queremos queremos resultados inmediatos
y adivina que al principio los cambios
son marginales pero si te disciplinas y
empiezas con el interés compuesto con el
tiempo los incrementos van a ser mayores
así como aquí y el problema de los
medios es que nos enseñan a la gente acá
nos enseñan a marck zuckerberg cuando
fundó facebook no hay cuando
prácticamente está en todo el mundo pero
no nos enseñaron cuando fue abriendo
universidad por universidad nos enseñan
a michael jordan cuando está acá pero no
nos enseñaron que ni siquiera lo
escogieron para su equipo en prepa
nos enseñan los años nos enseñan los
casos de éxito pero no nos enseñan el
trabajo no nos enseñan la disciplina no
nos enseñan el crecimiento en la
dinámica de crecimiento lo que nos
motiva a crecer todos los días eso no
nos los enseñan y cuando estamos
trabajando todos los días por algo que
queremos y no vemos los resultados que
queremos o vemos resultados muy
marginales que hacemos
lo dejamos
pero lo que vale lo que vale la pena en
la vida es tiempo requiere tiempo y
requiere trabajo y requiere de una
mejora continua yo cómo aplicó el
interés compuesto yo era consultor pero
dije qué pasa si en vez de dar mensajes
de puro mujer o en redes sociales puedo
dar un mensaje que trascienda
patrimonios mensajes que muevan
economías mensajes que muevan la actitud
en la forma en que la gente toma
acciones con su dinero y eso fue lo que
hice y adivinen cómo fue mi primer vídeo
hola señor idec y te voy a hablar sobre
el ahorro
a continuación entre 5 en las cuales tú
puedes ahorrar mejor será mejor
1 plantéate un objetivo para que quieres
ahorrar cuál es el objetivo una casa tus
vacaciones lo que sea ahorra 2
elimina el gasto se me gasto hormiga que
es el gasto hormiga pásele estar vos que
hables en hoteles
este vídeo nunca lo había mostrado en
público la primera vez que lo estoy
mostrando en público
lo perfecto es enemigo de lo practico
cuántas veces nos la pasamos en un
escritorio tratando de diseñar la idea
perfecta y cuando nos inhabilitamos no
hacemos nada porque estamos esperando
que hagas 100% sentir la cabeza ustedes
creen que eso hacía sentido 100% de la
cabeza
se los juro que no
pero el primer paso era charlar la
canica rodar era empezar la curva de
interés compuesto en una forma de
empezar de ejecutar porque el valor está
en ejecutar y en ir creciendo poco a
poco otra vez cambios marginales con el
tiempo este fue uno de los este buen
tercer vídeo después de que les enseñe
sabía esto que en méxico alrededor del
80% de las personas no ahorra o lo hace
de forma informal el tienes que decir
vamos el ahorro como algo que nos
dictaron nuestros padres o algo que nos
quiere imponer el gobierno pero tienen
malo no ahorrar gasto en lo que quiero
disfruto la vida
vivo el presente y qué pasó cuando
quieres comprar su primera casa el
primer carro te vas a endeudar qué pasa
cuando quieras invertir o vas a ser
económicamente dependiente en toda tu
vida cuando te retires o qué vas a
trabajar toda tu vida o si pasa me
compré un micrófono ahora un se utilice
mejor mejor vestida
aprendí a hacer animaciones aprendí a
ponerle un marquito
eso es eso fue mi curva de interés
compuesto y después un banco vio lo que
estaba haciendo y dijo ah y eso que está
haciendo por qué no vienes a hacerlo al
banco
la tarjeta de crédito sacarla o no
sacarla
habló el banco para ofrecerte una
tarjeta de crédito y no está seguro de
tramitarla aquí te van tres cosas que es
tomar en cuenta antes de sacar tu
primera tarjeta de crédito qué
diferencia no después me invitaron a dar
conferencias hoy ven a platicar a la
gente sobre eso que estás haciendo sobre
cómo administrar su dinero
y así fue y después hice un taller y
dije oye por qué no llevamos un taller
atom a diferentes lugares de méxico
hablarles de educación financiera
otra vez la importancia ahorrar y la
importancia de invertir la importancia
empezar a crear un patrimonio y como eso
va a impactar a ellos a sus familias a
sus hijos es un destino a todos
después
mi cargo y boris tampoco lo que está
haciendo por qué no vienes a hacerlo la
tele
y tenemos más aquí en las noticias como
siempre es un gusto recibir al experto
en finanzas morir
bienvenido un hola cómo estás un saludo
solo a todos los que nos están viendo un
placer estar aquí hoy en platícanos que
estuviste en colombia cómo te fue que
aprendiste estuve la semana pasada en
colombia padrísimo bueno colombia su
gente su tierra su vibra es increíble yo
en padre
anna aprendí una cosa de los colombianos
que quiero mencionar ahora aprendí la
palabra resiliencia resiliencia
resiliencia
la resiliencia es el poder que tienes de
levantarte cuando te caes
y eso también es el interés compuesto
es como vas avanzando en tus proyectos y
cómo te levantas aunque haya
dificultades y cómo te decides otra vez
a seguir creciendo poco a poco quién es
esta persona warren buffett uno de los
principales problemas ricos del mundo y
uno de los más grandes inversionistas de
toda la historia adivinen cómo se ve su
gráfica de riqueza si una gráfica del
interés compuesto
eso es cuánto vale la riqueza de warren
buffett
es una gráfica de interés compuesto
cambios marginales
entonces a resumidas cuentas que nos
quiere decir el interés compuesto nos
quiere decir no pienses en grande toda
la vida se han pasado enseñándonos que
pienses en grande que pienses que
quieres llegar a ser lo que pienses en
los grandes éxitos que puedes llegar a
lograr pero saben que nunca nos dicen
nunca nos dicen piensa en chico
yo hoy les vengo a decir eso piensen en
chico no piensen en grande y cuando les
digo piensen en chico es piensen en
todos esos pequeños aspectos en su vida
de todos los días como te puedes
disciplinar a ser un por ciento mejor en
cada cosa
todos los días todos los días
todos los días comprométete a hacer 1 %
mejor y sobre todo con ese que la curva
el interés compuesto requiere tiempo
requiere tiempo y eso es lo más difícil
ser resiliente y ser perseverante en el
tiempo y más en nuestras generaciones
entonces como empezamos a maurice les
voy a dar unos consejos primero que nada
yo sé que mucha gente que desea subir
aquí les va a decir lo mismo
encuentren su causa y en verdad se los
digo encuentren su causa para que para
que se levantan todos los días cuál es
el cambio que quieren generar en el
mundo si aún no encuentras tu pasión te
voy decir algo ayuda a los demás y vas a
encontrar tu pasión o ahí te va a otra
ayuda a los demás encontrar su pasión y
vas a encontrar la tuya
pero encuentra tu causa y te güiza y
otra cosa la gente hoy en día
hay mucha depresión porque hay mucha
gente que no encuentra porque está
viviendo una causa la gente está ansiosa
de seguir una causa si tú encuentras tu
causa y llegas y le dices al rebaño de
gente gente es por acá adivinen qué va a
pasar
te van a seguir
porque otra vez la gente está ansiosa
por tener una causa encuentra la tuya y
la gente que te siga
y más vale que se una buena causa
2 tus dones cuáles son tus dones si te
quieren ahorita si pudieras apostar de
que en algo puedes llegar a ser el mejor
del mundo qué sería
uno de mis grandes voy a aterrizar en el
primer punto encuentra mi causa a mí me
encanta el desarrollo económico el
desarrollo financiero porque yo creo que
es una de las formas más tangibles en
que puedes elevar la calidad de vida de
las personas esa fue mi causa esa fue mi
bandera ese fue mi estandarte encuentra
tus dones resulta que soy bueno
explicando
me lo decía no hay morir tú explicas
fregón siempre cuando tú explicas te
entiendo yo no soy ni financiero ni
economista yo soy ingeniero y los
ingenieros como aprendemos unos y ceros
cosas cuadradas así aprendemos es neta
lo que yo agarro un concepto lo
estructuró dentro del cuadrado de ser un
ingeniero y lo explico si hubiera sido
financiero economista probablemente no
estaría haciendo lo que estoy haciendo
hoy pero soy ingeniero
encuentra tus dones tu pared bueno y 3
sobre todo si quieres agregarle un
ingrediente atómico a tu causa un
ingrediente atómico para que tengan
resultados exponenciales vio la curva
interés compuesto vieron como esto es
así si quieren alcanzar esa curva antes
y no esperar tanto tiempo a todo su
menjurje de pasión y de para lo que son
buenos y su emprendimiento metal el
ingrediente atómico de las tecnologías
exponenciales que es hacia dónde va el
mundo cuáles son las tecnologías
exponenciales inteligencia artificial
big data la industria 4.0 block change
las redes sociales crear comunidades
esos son las tecnologías exponenciales a
lo que sea que te dediques nos lleve a
las finanzas métele el ingrediente
atómico y va a explotar tu proyecto va a
explotar porque a pase allá va todo
anticípate
y 4 utiliza el interés compuesto en lo
que sea tu proyecto